we're talking about angle between two
lines because this flows directly out of
the trig expansions which we reviewed
yesterday okay I want you to remember if
you've got a situation like this the air
between two lines unless they
specifically say hey we want this
usually refers to the acute angle
between the two lines okay obviously you
could pick the other one the obtuse
angle in this case but the relationship
between them is they're just
supplementary so whichever one you find
you just look at the question in the
wedding what it says and you're going to
use the same formula one way or the
other okay now if we want to find the
angle between the two lines if you
remember back to when we first proved
this it's based on the angle between
each of those lines and the x-axis so
you might want to fit that onto your
diagram okay
good morning so you may recall that we
have a nice very easy relationship to
find out any of these independent angles
okay so for example see this alpha over
here right there's a formula that we can
use in fact it's just straight out of
right angled triangle tree to find out
what alpha is when we know the gradient
of that line what's the way we do that
how do we find that what would negative
for the gradient of this line have to do
with this angle over here then remember
it's a two-unit formula think back
you've got three ratios I want you to
think which one will relate remember
this is a gradient right gradient just
rise over run if I if I put in like a
rise and a run it's gonna be ten isn't
it because you're not interested in the
hypotenuse sine and cos are both
connected to the hypotenuse which is
this one but your rise and your run are
going to be an opposite and adjacent
depending on which way you look at it
okay so in this case and that's the
gradient there would be equal to ten and
the angle I've given for that one is
alpha okay so we would say generally
speaking M equals 10 theta
I'm not using that particular form in
this case because we're it more
interested our theta today is this angle
the one between the two lines okay now
if that's for this steep negative line I
can do the same thing for the other line
so 1/2 is the other gradient I'm
interested in and it's equal to 10 but
not very good now these are all the
pieces that I need because the angle
between the two lines is based on these
two angles right it's just the
difference between them okay
so tan of theta that angle remember this
we're only thinking about the acute one
so therefore I put some absolute value
signs here why do I put absolute value
signs it can't be negative but what what
effect does that have why does that give
me the acute angle think about it think
yeah yet remember you remember this guy
right okay the angle you're going to get
is going to be either acute or obtuse
right it's either acute or obtuse so
it's going to be up here in quadrant one
or two yes but if you're in quadrant two
10 is negative if I want to avoid that I
just say well let's make 10 positive and
you will not get this angle you'll get
the acute one does that make sense okay
so theta we said was the difference
between those two angles so it's our
fart - beat up but we have a treat
expansion for this right do you remember
we reviewed yesterday all six are on the
board I planned out this board poorly so
let's just move over here
think about what fraction you're going
to get out of this do you remember what
big enormous fracture you to get 10 10
alpha minus the minus state alone on the
new rail and then you're gonna get the
opposite sign on the bottom right 1 plus
okay now the lovely thing about this is
that in this context I know exactly what
turnout for in 10 beta are I mean if I
were to try and go to alpha and beta and
do 10 inverse or something like that I'd
get weird awkward angles but I don't
need to because this formula doesn't
require alpha and beta
it requires 10 alpha and tamp it up
right so I can replace all of those just
with the gradients that were that's what
they're equal to okay so what I'm going
to do is
I'm gonna write this two times I'm gonna
write it generally I'm gonna write it
with m1 m2 as gradients and then we're
gonna work out this because I'm actually
interested in doing this angle in
radians so here's the general version
okay you've got your first gradient and
just second gradient like so and then
you've got your first gradient and your
second gradient again okay now quick
question is this one of those formulas
where it matters which one is one and
which one is two because there's some
formulas it matters and in others it
does not so does it matter in this one
and the answer is it doesn't matter
thank God it's one of those ones where
you can just so fire-and-forget
my question is why like look look up
here like I can see why I doesn't matter
which one of these because
multiplication is commutative but up
here usually subtraction it makes a
difference which one you put first so
why doesn't it matter
yeah yeah it's the absolute values isn't
it right because if for example I add
five take away three up here you'd get
two if I have three take away five you'd
get negative two but the absolute value
sort of fixes you up and you're back to
normal okay all right now what I'm gonna
ask you to do is can you please put
these in but for this particular
question for this example and make sure
your calculator is in radians mode
because you're going to get tan theta
equals so you're gonna have to undo that
with universe 3 once you've done that
you'll also be different depending which
mode you get it in so I'll give you a
second to work that out
once someone gets something can you give
it to me and maybe give me two decimal
places we'll do two decimal places
has anyone got a rate oh hold on
yeah did you did you get something yeah
cool
what are we get two decimal places 1.16
do I have some agreement Yes No maybe so
point nine eight they're kind of
different did we put this into our this
is this is just I put M 1 and M 2 in
there did I put it incorrectly that's
not a rhetorical question
did operating correctly this is a
substitution okay are you happy with
that
yes no there's someone get if we get an
alternative to 1.16 what was the
difference
I'm curious there the witch
oh yeah that that guy that's kind of I'm
all you just you've just got that number
is that right so you haven't okay so
once once we pass because we're
interested in angle yeah this is by the
way this is one of the tricky things
with with working in radians that the
angles and the numbers you get from the
angles often look remarkably similar
whereas if you get something like 47
degrees you know that's something else
okay what do I got my code you get
something what's going on Michael 1.35
do I have agreement on that
yes 1.35 is ever mrs. Lee's doesn't
trust you that's a bad sign you 12 team
now
let's quickly check right now one of the
ways that I know we're in the right
ballpark is because I did my best to I'm
draw reasonably to scale diagrams so I
would have a rough sense now 1.35 you
are not yet that accustomed to dealing
with radians but you're going to get
more used to it if it's an acute angle
what is the range in radians of this
ankle like what's the biggest it could
possibly be PI on to which you start you
need to start getting used to actually
seeing on your calculator which will
give you it to you in decimal so that's
about one point five seven I believe it
is because you know 3.14 you / - okay
so is this less than that one point five
seven yeah and it's pretty close to a
right angle which is sort of what my
diagram indicates
or to expect is that okay well thumbs up